[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
there's been a multi-year story that
we've been following and it's the story
of brexit and the primary question has
been
will brexit happen or will it not is
britain going to leave the european
union
or are they going to end up staying and
as i said
the day after the vote june 23
2016 it may never happen brexit may
never happen and of course we now know
that if the vote were to be held again
today
remain would likely win although there
are questions of
listen they did vote this way back in
2016
for how long does that vote remain
considered the will of the people there
are all sorts of questions like that but
more recently there have been much more
pressing sort of obstacles the former
prime minister theresa may
multiple times attempting to finalize a
deal
to structure the leaving of the european
union
and failing and ultimately the question
was was will she be able to outlast
the criticism and the calls for her to
leave
and ultimately she left and boris
johnson came in
boris johnson trumpian in many ways
certainly physically in his physical
appearance although that's not the most
important way
the leader of the conservative party now
the prime minister
will he finally do brexit for the
nationalists and the isolationists
who want the uk out of the eu
or will he also fail and so far it's
really not working particularly well for
him he has uh
between having one tory mp defect and
kicking 20
others out for not supporting him he
very quickly seems not to have the
numbers that he needs to get to the next
step in the brexit process so bottom
line
there has been one defection a tory mp
who bailed on boris johnson's party 20
other tory mps
are tories or at least they were but
they didn't
go along with what boris johnson wanted
and they were ejected and now all of a
sudden boris johnson finds himself in
yet another one of these embarrassing
scenarios for the pro-brexit
side giving the opposition control of
the
agenda in parliament johnson is soon
going to have to pay
face those prime minister's questions
for the first time which
can get very very crazy the opposition
of course is going to continue to try to
delay brexit and boris johnson
may call for a general election a really
a devastating defeat for johnson i know
that
you know the standards and the the sort
of rules of decorum and how to interpret
political happenings in different
countries can be difficult when we're
not
familiarized with the system and for
what the sort of overton window is for
what we can expect in terms of
what is possible on one side and the
other side but this is an embarrassing
defeat for johnson
here's video from yesterday in
parliament where members
of johnson's own party abandon him
and vote to allow a debate to once again
postpone brexit and the question becomes
does it seem as though this is
ultimately turning into an indefinite
postponement
total chaos breaking out take a look at
the first clip the eyes to the right
328 the nose to the left
301.
not a good start maurice order the eyes
to the right
328 the nose to the left
301. so the eyes have it
the eyes have it unlock another perk
of course point of order the prime
minister speaker
i think that thank you
mr speaker about the consequences of
this vote tonight it means that
parliament is on the brink of wrecking
any deal that we might be able to strike
in brussels because tomorrow's bill
would hand control of the negotiations
to the eu and that would mean
more diver more delay and more confusion
and it would mean that the eu themselves
would be able to decide how long to keep
this country in the eu and since i
refuse to go along
with that plan we are going to have to
make a choice
mr speaker i don't want an election the
public
don't want an election i don't believe
the right honourable gentleman
wants an election but if the house votes
for this bill tomorrow the public will
have to choose
who goes to brussels on october the 17th
to sort this out
and take this country forward what i
love about the system is that trump
definitely couldn't handle it
and i'm reminded of it because when you
look at boris johnson the look on
he he looks very trumpian like i said
but he has a slightly
uh uh more wits about him expression on
his face than trump
can you imagine donald trump ever having
to handle something like this i mean the
guy just literally could not he'd
implode until under this kind of
actual intense scrutiny and this
continuing to build as eventually boris
johnson
suffering abandonments and real chaos
breaks out jeremy corbyn ultimately
speaking
there is no consent in this house to
leave the european union without
a deal there is no majority
for no deal in the country
as i've said before if the prime
minister has a confidence in his brexit
policy
when he has one he can put forward he
should put it before
the people in a public vote
and so he wants to table a motion
for a general election fine
get the bill through first
in order to prevent an order
in order to take no deal off
the table
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
very rude
that when he turns up at our children's
school
as a parent he's a very well-behaved
fellow he wouldn't dare behave like that
in front of colin hall and neither would
i
don't gesticulate don't rant spare us
the theatrics
behave yourself be a good boy young man
be a good boy point them on to mystery
and blackbird
things are really getting crazy and
what's even wackier
is that this was all merely a debate
over what to order for lunch no i'm
kidding um but
this i still believe in the end that it
is a likely scenario that the uk
may never leave the european union if it
does
it may not happen under boris johnson
the way his prime ministership has been
going in its very early days at this
point in time and we actually
are asking you what you think will
ultimately happen we've pulled our
audience every you know once a year or
so since this has gone down
since the vote went down in 2016 if you
go to the community tab
on the david pakman show youtube channel
youtube.com
slash the david pakman show slash
community
do you think the uk will ever actually
brexit we will have results either later
this week
or maybe early next week we all knew it
was going to happen
because all the signs were there but
it's now
getting into overdrive trump allies are
now reportedly raising
millions of dollars to pay to find
damaging information about journalists
who are seen as unfriendly to donald
trump and the trump administration
and to then ideally use that information
to create antagonism campaigns against
journalists potentially to try to get
journalists fired
certainly there will be harassment from
trumpists on the basis of this
opposition research campaign against
members of the free press that trump
allies are undertaking
and you you can't miss the forest for
the trees here
this is a hallmark of authoritarian
dictatorships this is a hallmark of
police states this is
everything that is the opposite of what
the united states
is supposed to be this is putin-like
this is duterte-like and we knew trump
liked it we knew trump liked going after
the media trump going after specific
media outlets
even specific journalists in some cases
the fake news moniker
applied very haphazardly not to fake
news but merely to anything
that doesn't say glowing effusive things
about donald trump and this is now
an attempt to formalize attacks
on individual and specific journalists
these are
attempts in practice to silence
or ruin the lives of people who are
reporting critically about the president
of the united states one of the most
important things that a free and open
press can do and should be doing
axios has obtained the fundraising pitch
which has been deployed to get people to
donate to this cause
the cause that will ultimately gather
information that can be used to harass
or discredit
journalists and reporters can you
imagine getting an email
and being so disconnected from reality
having your priorities or your morality
so backwards
having such a fundamental
misunderstanding of what it is that is
important in the united states of
america when it comes to a free press
imagine getting an email saying we are
raising money
to go after journalists that are that
are antagonizing us and saying you know
what
that sounds like something i want to
donate to and apparently it isn't enough
to just call certain news outlets fake
news
and go after them trump's allies now
want to go after
specific reporters one of the people
involved is a republican consultant
named arthur
schwartz the primary targets of this
campaign
are said to be and listen to this cnn
and msnbc
not surprising all of the broadcast
networks
okay the new york times the washington
post
both of which have been doing
extraordinarily good just
plain old-fashioned investigative work
about this administration
buzzfeed and the huffington post and
this is the kicker
anyone else routinely included in what a
trump supporter sees
as bias and misinformation in their
coverage of donald trump
meaning it could be anybody i spoke to a
couple of friends in washington dc
who are not not republicans they're not
directly involved with this
but they've been in touch with people
who have knowledge of what's going on
they told me independent media
journalists that are seen as
particularly antagonistic to the
president
are not out of the realm of possibility
for being
targeted and harassed i'm not this is
not a delusion of grandeur
where i think i am on trump's radar or
on the the list of people that this
group is going to come after
i've merely been told that it is not
just corporate media that
is on the radar in terms of this uh
campaign so let's
immediately put to rest the trumpest
talking point
which i've already seen floating around
that this is no big deal
this is the same thing media matters
does media matters criticizes
and publishes media clips they aren't
going about
trying to attack and discredit
individual reporters
in the way that is being suggested here
that trump's allies want to do
we've seen this before and where we've
seen these attempts
to harass and target individual
journalists
it's places where human rights have been
decimated in any number of ways
russia world war ii era germany the
philippines
venezuela this is if we allow it to
happen the normalization of fascistic
behavior it doesn't mean we are a
dictatorship
but it is authoritarian fascistic
behavior
attack media as fake news treat them
poorly
kick out individual journalists talk
about journalism licenses and lawsuits
against media and then
smear campaigns against individual
journalists
for being journalists and doing their
jobs this is you know call it what you
want is it north korea is it stalin is
it all of them
and a word by the way to the gun nuts
you know the gun nuts say we need guns
to defend ourselves from a government
that becomes tyrannical
this is actually the type of thing that
if one believed the government would
become tyrannical would be sort of at
the top of the list starting to clamp
down
on a free and independent press and yet
i'm not hearing from any of the gun nuts
that they're worried about this
in fact a lot of the trumpest gun nuts
love this
because they've fallen hook line and
sinker they've drank the kool-aid
to borrow a term from jim jones uh
they've drank the cooler not a term but
in action i guess
uh they have drank the kool-aid on the
media is the enemy and we need to be
going after them rather than
defending them because it is a form of
potential government tyranny
this is a form of tyranny by special
interest group to put it another way
but it happens to be one that the gun
nuts don't seem
acutely affected by in a way that makes
them realize oh man
our threats our fears about tyrannical
government they're actually not the kind
that we really need the guns to defend
against
but this is starting to look like a form
of government tyranny understand that
the biggest threats to trump's
presidency
are the things that make the united
states what it is a free press
is a threat to donald trump's presidency
because he needs to hide the truth
to justify his reelection if people know
the truth there's no path to reelection
because his record is so atrocious high
voter turnout
is a threat to donald trump's presidency
well we know why that is trump benefits
from people not voting or not being able
to vote this is real
this is happening now and it has to be
stopped
in its tracks before it even gets going
make sure you're following me on twitter
at dpakman let me know what you think
follow the show on twitter at david
pakman's show and make sure to sign up
if you have amazon prime
subscribe with twitch prime at twitch.tv
david pakman this is free for everyone
who has amazon prime
but it supports the work that we do
twitch.tv
davidpak the david pakman show at
[Music]
davidpakman.com
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right today's new members of the day
are logan morrison and
sean ovary logan and sean i really
appreciate your support this is a
program
that depends on your support okay
go to joinpakman.com takes under a
minute to sign up
we get 97.1 percent of every payment we
pay just 2.9 percent to process
credit and debit debit card payments and
the rest of the money goes directly to
the show
once you sign up i hope you'll stay
signed up chris
tripp is today's long time sustaining
member of the day
he's been with us almost five years
really appreciate your support
and everybody's support take one minute
out of your day and sign up
at joinpackman.com it is time for hatred
mail what
is hatred mail this is hatred mail
we're getting to the oranges of this
investigation
so god bless united states america
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom this week's hatred
mail
introduces a new term we've talked a lot
about impeachment on the program
as a possible means to remove donald
trump although i don't believe that it
will
today we are introducing a new term take
a listen to this
impressments will not get trump out of
office
it will backfire spectacularly and
propel him
to a landslide victory i can't believe
david pakman admitted to being evil
progressives reveal in their nave vet
as though it's some kind of innocence
trump is behind you david feel the love
hello see what i did there
i guess this long comment qualifies me
as
unhinged you know i have to say i agree
with the hatred i don't believe that
imprisonment is going to remove trump i
i just don't don't see it happening and
uh i think we've got another urban
dictionary word that could maybe be
added in
with a definition referencing the david
pakman show impressment
i and all hatreds seem to be united
we will not remove donald trump from the
white house with
imprisonment and i encourage you to pass
the word along
make sure to fight patriotism by using
the coupon code
hatred 40 when you sign up for a
membership
at joinpackman.com you go to
www.joinpakman.com
you choose a monthly or a yearly
membership of your choice doesn't matter
which one
you hit the red sign up button and when
you're offered
the possibility of inserting a coupon
code you put in hatred 40 that's
h-a-t-r-i-o-t
4-0 hatred 40. your membership price
will be instantly dropped by 40 percent
and hatreds see this as a failing of
their patriotism when people hear hatred
mail
and instead of abandoning the david
pakman show they instead go to our
website and sign up with a coupon code
hatred 40.
this is just so devastating for hatreds
that i encourage
all of you fine folks to do it there's
no way to introduce this next story
other than simply to tell you what
happened which is that donald trump
congratulated poland on the 80th
anniversary of world war
ii of course the holocaust sort of
started with germany's invasion of
poland it's not exactly something to be
congratulating them about
other leaders sent messages of somber
remembrance and reflection
some even warning about sliding back
towards the type of authoritarianism
that
we saw early in the third nazi reich but
trump congratulates poland for having
been invaded by germany 80 years ago
take a look at this
i do have a great message for poland
that we have mike pence our vice
president
is just about landing right now
and he is representing me i look forward
to being there soon
but i just want to congratulate poland
it's a great country
with great people we also have many
polish people in our country
it could be 8 million we love
our polish friends and i will be there
soon there is no question i mean the
analysis here is very simple
trump has no idea what poland's role was
in world war ii
he just had no idea what the historical
context was
so he said i congratulate them i mean
just he just doesn't know anything
that's it trump was going to go to
poland
for the world war ii remembrance he
canceled the trip
because of hurricane dorian so he was
asked instead
for a message on this anniversary of a
very very dark day for poland back in
1939
and his message was congratulations
what was possibly the darkest day
in polish history and donald trump
congratulates them this is
indistinguishable from satire if i said
to someone
what's the worst possible thing you
could say to poland
on the 80th anniversary of being raped
and pillaged by the nazis
congratulations would be pretty high on
the list he does not know what happened
in world war
ii period poland lost a fifth of its
population during world war ii
a much bigger percentage of the jewish
population was lost in poland during
world war ii
congratulations guys a message of
congratulations
this is not very different than
congratulating
israel on holocaust remembrance day i
mean it's absolute and total idiocy the
the only other possibility i can think
of and tell me what you think about this
trump saying this happened because he
doesn't know what happened to poland in
world war ii
is one explanation there's a more
sinister one though
which is that trump knows germany
invaded poland in world war ii
and he likes it i don't actually think
that that's what's going
on here i don't i try not to attribute
to malice what can be
more than adequately explained by
stupidity and ignorance
and in this case uh trump has shown and
demonstrated over the last
many years no knowledge of history
whatsoever
and so i would attribute this to
ignorance and not malice we're only a
few days
from the 9 11 anniversary uh what is
donald trump
liable to say then not good
not good make sure you're following me
on instagram
david.pacman and while you are there
follow the show on instagram at david
pakman show we will take a quick break
our long-form deep dive
into the regulation of social media
is coming up next really really
important topic
and then much more coming up after that
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
youtube
welcome back to the david pakman show
many of you know i've been talking a lot
lately about youtube policies and
algorithms and how they affect our show
and other shows there's been a lot of
demonetization
youtube's been bearing independent
political shows like ours and there's a
bigger conversation about social media
and censorship
also happening which really exploded the
day i was on the joe rogan program
involving stephen crowder
and carlos mazza and that debacle as
well as recent
content and policy enforcement on
twitter
and this has really been relevant for
years but lately it's been snowballing
in particular with channels like ours
and other political channels
because there's a lot of misconceptions
about why youtube and facebook and
twitter
are doing what they're doing as well as
exactly what it is that they're doing so
let's
talk about how users and content
creators are affected
but then talk about the big picture
issues in social media and how we should
be thinking about them i'll tell you
what the problems
are but i'll also tell you what the
problems are not
and maybe most importantly the solutions
that we should be looking at
so on platforms like youtube and twitter
the more popular you are as a content
creator the more likely
you are to be targeted with censorship
and demonetization
if and until you get big enough to be
exempted from some restrictions because
of a special account status
that can be available in some cases but
then
social platforms will sometimes enforce
policies differently
when there's a high profile controversy
they'll be accused of platforming
harmful speech
or of being anti-free speech they start
feeling the heat from the public
from one side or the other and then they
start making decisions and enforcing
policies in ways we haven't necessarily
seen before and often
those enforcements will happen in ways
that
fly directly in the face of both the
letter
and the spirit of the terms of service
of a platform
or their mission statement about free
expression and dialogue or whatever
and sometimes they'll even end up making
up new policies on the fly
right in the middle of a scandal
sometimes i'll happen to agree
or disagree with a specific call that a
company might make whether it's taking
someone off of a platform or reversing a
ban on someone who
i didn't think actually deserved it but
the problem
as i've said before is the inconsistency
a company will claim to stand for
certain values
and then they'll fold under pressure
when it's a better pr move to do the
opposite and it creates a completely
dysfunctional ecosystem for everyone
and sometimes the problems are even more
fundamental we upload
about eight videos to youtube a day and
on some days as many as 75 percent are
demonetized for not being quote
brand safe so we don't make any money
from those videos
sometimes it's predictable based on
youtube's demonetization guidelines
but the problem is the effect that this
has on
our ability to produce serious news
without concerns about monetization to
be clear
i wouldn't and i haven't changed the
content of the show
to stay monetized on youtube i cover the
stories that are important
youtube can and does demonetize them but
the david pakman show is a small
business
and i need to make projections and have
an understanding of where will revenue
come from
so this application of policy is a
distraction
from simply producing the best content
we can
if youtube will allow us to collect
revenue from our videos
that's great or if a large portion of
our videos will be demonetized then we
need to deal with it and figure out how
else to fund the show
the real problem is that by all accounts
our content should be monetizable
we don't show graphic violence we don't
use profanity i'm never sitting here
using drugs or harassing people or
belittling people based on their race or
gender
our content would be monetized were it
not
for advertisers imposing their will on
youtube
and youtube having little choice but to
go along with it this is not a left wing
right wing thing
people on the right like to say it's
happening to them
because they're conservative but it's
happening to independent political shows
that are across the political spectrum
including mine it doesn't seem to be
affecting the big corporate media
outlets that have youtube channels
nearly as much and sadly this is part of
a theme we've been seeing with youtube
lately
independent political channels on the
left and right
the david pakman show kyle kolinsky
steven crowder these types of people
we've realized that youtube is in
general
hindering our shows and deterring people
from watching
bolstering legacy corporate media
outlets that have youtube channels
whether it's cnn
nbc news or late night talk shows in
july of 2018
youtube actually made an announcement
that they would start making quote
authoritative news sources more visible
on the platform
in a press release youtube said today
we're announcing steps we're taking with
the google news
initiative to support the future of news
in online video
and product features we've been working
on to improve the news experience on
youtube we believe
quality journalism requires sustainable
revenue streams
and that we have a responsibility to
support innovation in products and
funding for
news they go on to say authoritativeness
is essential to viewers
especially during fast-moving breaking
news events so we've been investing in
new product features
to prominently surface authoritative
videos when you're watching a youtube
video you see a list of other suggested
videos on the right side of the page
on desktop or below the video on mobile
when you're finished watching a video
before the next one plays you see a
similar set
of suggested videos appear what shows up
here
these suggested videos is controlled by
youtube's recommendation algorithm a
large portion of our traffic
has always come from these suggestions
someone's watching a video
about whatever youtube suggests they
watch
another video by the david pakman show
about a related topic
this has been a really important source
of video views for us and it's a really
good way of allowing people
to discover our channel for the first
time our youtube dashboard
tells us where our video views come from
and we're now getting only about
half of the recommendations that we were
getting about a year ago
and the decline started right after
youtube announced they would prioritize
quote authoritative news sources so not
only is youtube demonetizing the views
that we do get they're also causing us
to get fewer views to begin with
which hurts the channel now this is not
some underhanded plot to destroy the
david pakman show
yes they're changing their algorithm in
a way that hurts us
but i understand what they're trying to
do
and why they're trying to do it sadly
this is the same reason that breitbart
and infowars and other extremists fake
news sites don't show up in search
results
when you go to news.google.com google
and youtube
want to placate advertisers by
preventing accusations that they are
perpetuating
or allowing the monetization of
misinformation
fake news hate news and extremist
content but the reality is that whatever
the motivation
my channel similar independent channels
which should not be lumped in with fake
news and hate channels
are getting caught up in it and frankly
it could destroy many of the channels
like ours if it continues and so far
it's continuing
we all know the types of channels
youtube wants to make less visible
uh the sandy hook conspiracy people
alt-right extremism
red pill black belt people uh
misogynists racists homophobes people
targeting others on the basis of sexual
orientation
all of the types of channels that over
the years
youtube has gotten a lot of flack for
platforming
youtube is fighting a negative image of
in part being a garden of nut jobs and
hate and extremism youtube wants to fix
their brand
and maintain their brand i can see why
they want to do that
but shows like ours are getting hurt by
the algorithm
to the detriment of speech and ideas to
understand how to interpret and deal
with this
we need to have some shared starting
point something that
many people do which completely fails to
properly frame the conversation about
censorship and demonetization is to say
that youtube and other social media
companies like twitter and facebook
are left-wing they say these platforms
are silencing or disincentivizing speech
that's politically incorrect or speech
that is generally considered offensive
when it comes to race nationality gender
sexual orientation religion
many people are taking this and
concluding that the social media
companies have a left-wing agenda
yes hateful or offensive speech
is more likely to come from someone on
the right
when stephen crowder calls carlos mazza
a gay mexican
lispy queer and gets his videos
demonetized
that's not something you're really going
to hear from people on the left very
often and it's the kind of speech
that's going to get you in trouble on
some of these social media platforms
in that sense it's possible that right
wingers
face more repercussions than people on
the left i don't know that to be the
case
but it's possible but using that to say
that these companies are fundamentally
progressive or left-wing
doesn't actually help us understand
these issues and it's not accurate
conservatives have a conspiracy theory
that social media companies
are simply bleeding heart political
activists waging
an ideological war against the right the
reality is these companies
have known as companies ethical or
ideological philosophies or positions
they are motivated by business interests
these companies by the way
as i said to joe rogan are also very
right winger libertarian right
libertarian in many ways in terms of the
policies they support in the role that
they play
google is currently in an anti-trust
battle with the department of justice
facebook is the subject of a huge
anti-trust investigation
by the federal trade commission these
companies are huge
tax dodgers they want to self-regulate
they lobby for deregulation the same as
the air polluters and the big banks and
the gun manufacturers
what google and facebook and twitter do
every day in washington
is in the most literal sense the
opposite of progressivism
having an internal culture that's
socially progressive
first and foremost doesn't mean that as
a company they are progressive
in their public role but in addition to
that even what appears to be left-wing
in
internal culture is often just brand
management their politically correct
content policies and the way they
enforce them
and what they say publicly about content
policies it's not virtue signaling
it's a signal to their advertising
clients
and to their shareholders and this
should be obvious
youtube and twitter clearly have no
authentic
principled stance on protecting
offensive speech
or on combating offensive speech this
was most recently demonstrated
by their flip-flopping embarrassing
flip-flopping on the crowder mazda
situation one side got mad at youtube
youtube conceded the other side got mad
at youtube
youtube then conceded to them they
panicked they tried to find the right
balance between
protecting their image in the eyes of
advertisers and
uh understanding that that's the source
of their revenue but protecting their
image
in the eyes of the public as well who
are the people that need to watch those
advertisements
youtube isn't evil or virtuous twitter
isn't left-wing
or right-wing these are corporations
they exist to generate revenue and
perpetuate themselves
so maybe you're saying well we still
have this problem though that these
companies have a monopoly on social
media and they're silencing
offensive speech they're recklessly
demonetizing political commentators who
don't deserve it
and that is what we're faced with a
solution that's
often proposed is that we regulate these
companies that we use the government
somehow to enforce
free speech on the platforms which is
already problematic language
they want us to treat these platforms
like public squares establish
free speech protections for all of the
users
but these arguments fall flat the first
amendment protects you
from censorship by the government not by
private entities
the government shouldn't be able to
force a company to allow you
to use their software and their networks
this isn't a civil liberties issue
social media companies do and should
have every legal right to maintain and
enforce
their own content policies to prioritize
certain content
to protect their brand or for any other
reason that they have or none at all
unless they're doing something like
discriminating against
users of a certain race or religion
which violates the law
what government body is going to enforce
so-called free speech on social media is
it going to be congress
whose political bias changes every few
years will it be the fcc or the ftc as
donald trump is thinking of doing
whose political bias also changes every
few years
we know that the current administration
wants based on this
executive order that they're putting
together for them to be the ones who
decide
based on their politics who gets to say
what
and which platforms get punished that's
dangerous
conservatives don't want this type of
government regulation
anywhere else they just want government
regulation
here because things haven't been going
their way
the free market has demonstrated that
offensive content
is bad for business and they now want
special
big government nanny state protections
against what is being caused
by free market capitalism quite frankly
or the version of it that we have
i'm being negative and negatively
impacted by one of these companies
youtube is hurting me financially
they're diminishing my ability my
ability to voice my opinion
but that's not making me lose my
objectivity about the rights of private
companies or how
impractical it would be to have the
government oversee
social media content the first step in
the correct direction is going to be for
us to stop viewing social media as one
collective
thing or entity different social media
platforms
serve different purposes twitter has
developed a service that's very
different than facebook
the mechanics are different the culture
is different the etiquette is different
some platforms allow porn some don't
some platforms allow spamming some don't
some platforms require you use your real
name and others don't
all social media platforms are different
because they're geared
to different markets and have different
purposes the average person using tumblr
is different than the average person
using quora for example
or at least they use the two platforms
for very different reasons
social media companies intentionally
develop their platform
to have a particular environment catered
to the market they want to serve
in the same way that a platform designed
for professional networking
wouldn't be any good as a medium for
sharing funny memes and vice versa
a platform designed to serve a somewhat
universal mainstream user base and
attract mainstream advertisers
may not function properly as a platform
for exchanging
controversial ideas or vice versa many
social media platforms that are marketed
as free speech alternatives to
mainstream platforms
some are i like personally others seem
to be cesspools of hate and sketchiness
but the idea of forcing that content
onto privately owned platforms that
don't want it
and maybe financially harmed by it
doesn't make sense
youtube serves a particular purpose it's
an invaluable
service to the vast number of content
creators who otherwise
wouldn't have a platform to so
lucratively distribute their content
it's been a really great thing for most
independent video creators
i've been asking for a more clear
understanding
of how the demonetization works as it
pertains to my content
i'm not creating content that's fringe
or extreme or disturbing or gory or
whatever
the way that youtube is suppressing many
independent channels as if they were
doing that
is antithetical to what made youtube
cool and interesting to begin with but
ultimately it is youtube's right
it's my right to complain about it it's
my right to leave youtube
or start my own youtube if that's what i
want to do maybe
it is actually the best business
decision for them maybe
it's just more worth it to youtube to
take a better safe than sorry approach
to the way that they're demonetizing me
and to just push the corporate media
channels and not worry too much about
the collateral damage to programs like
mine
in the end i don't know that i can do
that much about it
this is why it's so important for the
audiences
of independent political talk shows like
ours to realize that the shows can only
exist
unfettered through direct support from
the audience
especially if the youtube algorithm and
the demonetization stuff gets worse
it's not just a talking point it's not a
way to get uh
people to sign up for david pakman show
memberships it's just reality
if we don't have reliable youtube
revenue and we don't have reliable
financial support from the audience
we may have to figure out something else
maybe i'll have to get a different
job if you're not on youtube to watch
makeup tutorials or cat videos and what
you want to do is watch content like
ours
that's trying to shake things up trying
to deal with serious issues in an adult
way
and rubbing some people the wrong way
admittedly then maybe
we all need to assess our roles as
consumers
of shows like this one even though these
shows can be accessed for free
they're a cost to the creators employee
salaries employee health insurance
rent internet electricity equipment
connectivity so many other things
a political commentary show relying more
on direct support
from the audience than on youtube ad
revenue is actually probably a better
paradigm for everybody involved it means
that
if you are a patron of something that
you value
and you're educated and entertained by
it instead of you
and your clicks becoming a commodity to
youtube's bottom line
through your cable subscription or
watching ads or whatever else
it would mean content creators would be
more free to do and say what they want
unbehold into advertisers and that
freedom and integrity
is something that's crucial for shows
and the political commentary sphere
it probably also means that you might
even end up with more content creators
to choose from because they'd be better
funded
or you'd have higher quality content
because people doing
this part-time could focus on it
full-time as an example
when you pay for content you're not just
getting what you paid for
you're investing in something you value
so that it can
sustain and grow and improve so this is
not a promotion
for our patreon page or our membership
program this is something i personally
find not only fascinating but of crucial
importance from a media studies point of
view and it's something that applies to
the entire digital media industry
these are my thoughts but it is
something that is affecting
online political shows like this one and
i do believe
that independent political shows are
particularly important to protect
when we see this administration wanting
to come up with new and novel ways to
suppress speech they don't like
and to mandate speech they do like be
published
regardless of what a private company
wants to do what we ultimately need
is a big picture meta shift
in how we think about online content how
we consume it
and what we are willing to do to sustain
it
and guard it from outside influences and
i hope that's what you'll take away from
this
today the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
it's been a while since i had a clip for
you of just good old-fashioned religious
nuttery that's indistinguishable from
mental illness and i've sort of been
getting away from these sorts of clips
unless they're linked to something in
the news because i think most of the
audience at this point has a pretty good
understanding and sense of this
completely unhinged
religious zealotry but today we actually
have
a an example of religious nuttery that's
directly linked to
the news and specifically hurricane
dorian hurricane dorian
is a real thing people have died untold
damage is being done
president trump sending confusing
messages about it saying it's going to
hit
alabama but it isn't and there are
people refusing to evacuate this is
this is real it's as real as real gets
there are people
who are uh losing their lives and at
risk of losing their lives because of
this storm
and in the midst of all this in comes a
grifter
named kat kerr who shows up
and records herself commanding the
hurricane
with a stick in the name of jesus in
some kind of bizarre
uh prayer i don't even know what to call
it my question
is can we call this anything other than
mental illness
is there any other categorization for
what i'm about to show you let's look at
it together
so right now at this moment we take
authority over dorian
that has no right off the coast
of this state or anywhere and we
hit that storm to the
east right now and i'm gonna do it three
times
we headed to the east we headed to the
east and commanded
you go to the east out away from land
we declare you would do no destruction
in any way what
won't tolerate it so father i thank you
for this honor
i'm privileged to be here on the little
coast of florida
and we saved that storm
your end is coming
we don't tolerate your presence we won't
tolerate you coming ashore anywhere
or causing any harm death or destruction
we speak on behalf of those who have
already been affected by god we thank
you for a rapid recovery
and restoration for all of them right
now but we decree and declare
you dorian your days
and ours are numbered
and we bash you she tells the storm
that its end is coming well yeah i mean
storms end eventually that's not much
uh that's not very prosaic i must say do
we just need to call this what it is
mental illness how else would we
describe something like this
this is like a a crazy person uh
yelling at a cloud i mean this is no
different and if you look more into
i've never heard of this person before
but so many people emailed me that i
said i've got to figure out more about
her
she has a website called the revelation
zone it has a whole bunch of stuff on it
including videos frequently asked
questions about
eternity some of the stuff seems
straight up satirical but i don't i
don't think it is like
i i wonder is it possible this is all a
joke because no other explanation would
suffice
check out some of the questions she
answers from kids on her website 14 year
old emily from jacksonville florida
wrote
are there oceans with sharks and
jellyfish in heaven
and catker wrote yes there is a crystal
sea which comes from the river of life
that flows out of god's throne
oh yeah of course also the bible states
that there are fish of all kinds in the
water
and the crystal sea is big enough to
hold huge sailing ships
another question from trey who is age
six from richmond virginia
question is letting trey write to this
woman a form of child abuse i think
that's something we should consider
six-year-old trey asks is there an art
easel
and a t-rex in heaven kat kerr says yes
to both questions
since i saw art galleries there i don't
know if she means she was in heaven at
one point
i am certain they would have easels to
paint on also there are representations
of an
all of all animal life that god
originally created so dinosaurs
including the t-rex
can be seen in the park area of heaven
ah the park area of course
they are so tame that you can actually
ride on them that's right
there are tamed t-rexes
living in the park area of heaven
next to the easels which must exist
because kat kerr
knows that there are art galleries in
heaven and if there are art galleries
there must be easels with which
the art is made this is dangerous
this is dangerous children should not be
exposed to this woman we we've
previously discussed on the program
it's uh we haven't done this for a while
and i'm now getting myself fired up and
talking about it
we've previously discussed on the
program is it
a form of child abuse to place the
irrational fear of going to hell
in the minds of children from a young
age it is
other forms of causing a rational fear
or persistent fear in children
can be considered child abuse is the
fear of
of hell rather uh considered child abuse
in some way shape or form
that's something we've discussed this is
crazy
to let children interact with this woman
and this might not come as a huge shock
to you
this woman is a big trumpist i was
looking through her twitter account
yesterday
she has tweets about trump 2020 events
and just how great the national day of
prayer is and this type of thing
is that surprising to you did anybody
think from the video of her
trying to hit the hurricane with a stick
in the name of jesus
that she might have been a bernie
supporter i don't know that that many
people were confused about that
but in case you were this is a major
trump supporter
really wacky stuff and i guess what she
did didn't work because the storm still
hit
but the way that these folks work if you
were to confront her
she would say well no no no i did move
the hurricane
my prayer with the stick made it so that
even more people weren't killed by
hurricane dorian which is of course
exactly the type of unfalsifiable belief
that doesn't really pass muster if you
apply even an iota
of critical thinking uh this is not a
joke
this stuff ruins people's lives it
completely takes over their worldview in
a sort of unrelated but related story of
religious nuttery we really recently
found out that
one of the main pushers or advocates of
so-called
conversion therapy where people can get
therapy
to stop being gay um is a gay man and
uh i know it didn't come as a shock to
me i'm guessing
it doesn't come as a shock to many
people in our audience but this stuff is
not just
oh these are just their beliefs and
everyone's entitled to their beliefs and
ah blah blah blah
okay they're entitled to their beliefs
but they're using those beliefs
in a weaponized form to ruin the lives
of
gay and lesbian people to ruin the lives
of children with irrational fears and
and beliefs that are not based in
reality this actually has a real world
impact uh and it also has the impact by
the way if you're really religious
and you think something like this works
you might choose not to evacuate for the
hurricane because you think kat kerr
is going to use her stick and get the
hurricane out of the way then you get
killed by the hurricane this stuff has a
real world
impact and we cannot write it off as
just benign spirituality because it's
simply not that
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p i'm getting different
versions
of this question more and more take a
listen to this
yeah david this is brian from utah i was
just wondering
what your thoughts on the easiest way of
beating
biden in the democratic primary would be
for either sanders
or warren to drop out maybe to
consolidate the progressive vote
it just kind of seems like they're taken
away both from each other
anyway just one of your thoughts on that
that would work if that's a good idea
how that would play out all right thank
you yeah so listen i'm getting this
different versions of this question more
and more if bernie drops out
warren gets his support crushes biden if
warren drops out
bernie gets her support crushes biden i
understand
the implicit logic of it they are the
two most progressive candidates
therefore
certainly if people who like bernie can
no longer support bernie because he's
out
they'd go to warren and vice versa the
polls don't bear this out there seems to
be
a very demographically aligned second
choice for both bernie
and warren the plural from the the last
poll i saw on second choices
a plurality of bernie voters would go to
biden
if bernie were to lose or leave the race
a plurality of warren supporters would
go to kamala harris
if elizabeth warren were to lose or
leave the race
demographically that makes sense
ideologically
it doesn't make sense and we need to
account for that so
if people have other polls that suggest
different
trajectories for bernie voters and
warren voters respectively if the two
candidates were to lose or leave the
races
their respective races let me know but
from what i've seen
it is not mathematically obvious that
either bernie or warren
abandoning these races would lead to a
consolidation of support around the
other candidates such that they would
surpass joe biden if bernie
bales it may actually boost biden more
than warren
if warren bales it may boost harris more
than bernie
and joe biden may still be in the lead
which is why i think we should be
cautious about assuming that the path
forward is for one of the two
bernie or warren to say i'm out in order
to help the other person now
if if they left and said please support
x if bernie said i'm getting out please
support warren or if warren said
i'm getting out please support bernie
that may change the dynamics but that is
not what the polling for now seems to
suggest disagree with me have
contradictory polling data
let me know we've got a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about the
conversion therapy group founder who has
come out as gay and apologized
we will talk about democrats continuing
to want to look into donald trump's hush
money payments to mistresses
and we will talk about a non-drinker who
was wrongly charged with driving under
the influence who has now picked up a
nice
settlement from new york city all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
become a member at joinpackman.com or a
patron
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
to instantly get access to the world
famous bonus show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com